okay hello hello everybody good evening
it's very good to see you again
so I come to the end of almost a
week-long visit to
um to Ukraine with lots of visits
technical visits and just now meeting
with the president so I'm at your
disposal for any question that you may
have thank you very much from NBC News
the Ukrainian government is warning the
Russians May Lodge a fresh a fresh
offensive potentially in the coming
weeks have the Russians given you any
assurances they will not attack power
plants again like they had in the past
well obviously I do not consult with
them on military operations this would
be completely out of my mission but I am
very clear about the absolute necessity
to exclude nuclear facilities nuclear
power plants from any military action
this is of course a permanent message
that I have for everybody
[Music]
as far as the zapparito power plant is
concerned what are the working
conditions like for the iae staff that
are on the ground there is it is it
workable conditions then second of all
is there still enough qualified
personnel there to control all those
processes because we have heard that
some of the Ukrainian Personnel That Was
Then basically taken over by the
Russians has decided to leave well there
are two there are two issues there to
start uh with the with the last point
that you're making it is true that there
has been quite a dramatic reduction in
the number of Staff normally a facility
like this has around 10 000 people
working and now we are down to 3 000
more or less of course this may vary it
is sufficient to run the operation in
the current conditions you may be
reminded that the the the plant is not
producing energy at the moment it is
still operating at a very low regime
that is needed what we call in the
jargon cold and hot shutdown the six
reactors so we they do have the people
to do this operation but of course it is
a source of concern my technical stuff
is looking at this including the isams
experts there on site and regarding
their your your first question on their
their conditions they are fine of course
this is a a facility that is under
special circumstances but they are fine
and they can do their work correctly I
am in contact with them daily several
times several times a day
uh I have a question my question is
about Department intermissions over
International economic energy agency
when they will start to work at all
stations plans and what they will do
there can you please yes of course well
they have started with the exception of
kimlitskid which is going to start
tomorrow or the day after tomorrow but
they have started they they are there
already and they have a long list of
things that they need to do you know a
nuclear power plant is a very big
place where there are many things that
need to be checked we are going through
a number of activities that we are going
to be working with the of course the the
Ukrainian regulator and also in Ergo
atom there is apart from that there are
some issues related to supply chain in
the current conditions it is very
difficult sometimes to get replacements
pieces equipment that are needed for the
normal functioning of the plant so we
are we're looking at lists of equipment
that in algorithm and the the regulator
have submitted to us and we're going to
be working to try to provide those so
each each plant is different each plant
has its different characteristics and
and and issues and this is why we have a
permanent mission of experts at each
each one of them so we can look into
what is needed at every place according
to their needs of course
director we're almost a year into this
war now can you just lay out the stakes
here how dangerous is this situation a
major conflict in the country with so
many nuclear power plants well the the
the good side of the answer could be
that almost a year after the beginning
of a conflict the first major
conventional war waged and on a
territory that has a vast nuclear
infrastructure we we've seen difficult
moments we had very difficult moments
challenges there blackouts where the
facilities were operating in emergency
mode and we saw the resilience of the
system this is very important we saw
that the regulator were prepared we saw
that the staff at the plants was
reacting in the way it should they
should and and we are here and this is
the other the other thing this as any I
would say
or it has a transformative
effect and we don't know exactly how it
will affect us all in the end but one
thing I can say the iaea has changed the
iaea is been doing and is being called
to do things that one could have not
imagined before and so and also for us
it has been a challenge and we are very
I would say committed to continue doing
what we are doing I think uh the the the
situation is very precarious as I'm
always saying I'm very worried about
suppuricia I'm very worried what you
said in your first question is an
element but even without new offensives
or new campaigns it's always on the
front line and only today there were two
major explosions in the vicinity it was
not at the plant itself but we were in
alarm we were in contact so so we know
every day that that a nuclear accident
or an accident having serious
radiological consequences may take place
any day this is why I'm so concerned and
this is why I'm still saying and I will
continue to say it the establishment of
a protection Zone around the plant is
indispensable
what's it like dealing with rosatom is
your relationship with is it cordial as
a professional it's professional it's
professional as it should be it's
professional and if we had heard some
reports that the Russians also were
thinking of such a connecting evaporator
to their own empowerment have you seen
anything no I haven't seen anything to
that effect and if it was the case our
daily updates would report that of
course
how are talks going about a protection
well I I some I have been saying I would
I would I would love to come and tell
you it's it's it's it's agreed uh
everybody agrees on something
which I believe is important uh the
plant needs to be protected there is no
doubt about it uh what I I need this is
perhaps my challenge because the parties
are not negotiating with each other it's
the director general of the iea putting
forward uh proposals that are hopefully
viable that are reasonable that are
technically sound and that they they do
not get into areas where it should not
get into the military operations or
considerations because of course that
would be inappropriate so this is what
I'm doing I continue to do that I had a
good conversation with the president
about that I am going to visit Russia
soon
pressing for this I think it's
absolutely necessary
do you find a spirit of Good Will of
cooperation when you meet with Russian
officials that you feel they wish to
cooperate and Achieve something here
well your question is it is an
interesting one because it has a
subjective element to it do I feel that
they want to cooperate I have a
professional engagement with them they
know that they when the the iaea is
engaging and is asking and requesting
objectively technical questions that
they have to comply with because at the
end of the day we should not forget that
the safety standards that we are trying
to implement have been agreed by
everybody
everybody so until uh the I have an
indication that that there is no
engagement I want to believe that the
professional engagement is there please
don't misunderstand me this is not a
value judgment I'm not here attributing
merits or lack thereof but my
professional engagement is absolutely
necessary with them as you may
understand
pointed out that we have made it almost
a year now with without a nuclear
disaster do you worry the world is
becoming complacent about the threat yes
I worry I worry that's an excellent
point I worry that that this is becoming
routine
that people may believe that well
nothing happened so far so is the
director general of the Ia crying wolf
and nothing is happening well it can
happen anytime
so and my my duty is to do everything I
can to prevent that from happening
when we had Fukushima we could blame
Mother Nature who are we going to blame
if something happens I have been saying
we need to do this I have been saying
this would be the consequences of a
radiological accident we need to avoid
it while there is time so I hope my my
call is heard
but thank you very much I hope to see
you soon thank you thank you